ABCs of AI P is for prompt engineering
prompt engineering is a bit of a
catch-all phrase used to describe the
calibration of natural language input or
prompt into an AI model and the
management of how that model interacts
with those prompts so just like how a
vague or leading question to a human or
a search engine can really mess with
your results with an ml model you want
to make sure that you're tailoring your
questions so they don't impact the
relevant accuracy of your answer at a
baseline you want to make sure you're
being specific providing relevant
context for your
request and aware of the limitations of
your model check out more on The Human
Side of prompt Engineering in this video
and let us know what AI topics you want
to learn more about on the next episode
of